but let's put it in perspective like
they can sell this and they can do a
million streams and so forth and so on
but they don't have somebody asking them
about second round knockout and trying
to constantly box them in see what i'm
saying like i would trade a clean slate
for what you're what you're praising me
for right now i traded for queensland
that's how crazy all that [ __ ] was but
nobody understands that you see what i'm
saying everybody comes and acts like oh
you got so much you can do so much but
i'm shackled to that [ __ ]
do you feel like that you're sh you you
do you feel like that's like
obviously look at the end of the day
if
you know
if you've made hip-hop history you've
been a part of hip-hop history right and
you're also someone who's kind of
not
accessible not very you know like i said
you kind of get in and get approachable
not really accessible right right okay
so you know i think it's you have to
kind of expect
we're sitting here for two hours right
i'm gonna bring it up it's it's it's a
highlight of you know
that's that you know what that's if
that's if you don't really know the
whole catalog bro like if you knew the
whole catalog like so i got like
three thousand
five hundred or something songs
registered mm-hmm right registered which
is
like sounds you know how much that is
because you did the math that fast right
right so
that's that's that's it so so let's
let's take let's take you might have
more registered songs than any rapper
ever to be maybe that may be yeah it is
i could i could show you the proof but
and i probably would like right after we
get off but now so in my mind right and
in the mind of the people who know me
best
that one song that everybody keep
talking about if we just subtract that
one song from the catalog there's still
30 yeah
you understand where i'm coming from i
get it so that's exactly where we stand
i understand how that could be
frustrating it's not frustrating to me
i'm almost
i'm almost looking at the rap community
like they're slow
and this is why we're in the [ __ ] that
we're in right and that's why i've
stopped
trying to
augment the direction that that's that's
going to get us because they're not just
doing it with me they're doing all the
artists out here
they're taking narratives that will
shackle people to things
that
that
muck up the gears
and make it so that they can't you know
make an impact
of value
they make it they turn it into something
that the only value that can come from
it is like you know the ops right
what what they're selling
and how they're changing the narrative
and how you know maybe something
unfortunate can happen to the
you know to the to the to the delight
you know what i mean or just the
balancer or the equalizer they want
something to happen to the equalizer man
well listen the way i look at it is this
right
i think that that situation is
historical to in the same way that i
think that that roundtable that you dmx
pun and mike geramino was historical so
as a hip-hop fan as someone who
participated as a consumer in that era
like you know personally that's
something i want to you know i want to
ask you about that day when you were
sitting at that table in the same way i
want to you know ask you about
i specifically remember right
participating as a as a fan in that
situation so beautiful man and
and yet again i can stand here on this
side of the fence and say okay so let's
look at the round table like
what happened to everybody on the panel
like including me man